new age conservatism is classicalism
and like just from looking at all the
people who identify that way now so
that's
where i've always been um and
the democrats progressives liberals
whatever you want to call them on that
side
it's just the most toxic behavior i've
seen from a group of people in a long
time
like i haven't even see i've never met a
religious person
that was far right that treated me that
way the way that people
do
has it been kind of disappointing for
you to see
what you described with the gay
community i was never like really
in the gay community in that way i
actually had a
gay i had a gay radio show on siriusxm
so i guess i had like a year or two of
my life that i was sort of in that world
um but i never really felt like i was in
it i was also closeted later and
just just the way my life was it's just
how it is um
but to see now like when people talk
about the gay community it seems like
they've gone from being
edgy and controversial and sort of
subversive and interesting and there was
music and fashion and blah blah
to now it's just like the worst sort of
social preening
political hysterics yeah yeah like i
have
friends of mine that went to you know
they go to florida pride parades
and they get they get harassed like
verbally not thank god i don't think
anyone's like throwing anything at them
but they get verbally harassed like
cursed at
and just for being a conservative for
believing in something different
he doesn't you know my friend david
broke back patriot
um what's upsetting to me the most
i think over the last two years is
when i and this is maybe an ego thing a
little bit i'm not gonna lie
but it's also a comfort thing when i
used to go out to these pride marches
and
lesbian events or lgbt events like you
know playlist live
vidcon whatever kids used to come up to
me and cry
like actually i'm not even kidding like
cry telling me that i saved their life
or i at least changed their life i
helped them create a closet help them
be who they were be who they are it's
like i'm the same person that i was back
then
yeah i just am more honest and open with
my opinions now even though
to me there's still pretty you know
mainstream mainstream opinions
now when i go to pride parades and i go
to safe spaces
i'm not even kidding i don't feel safe
anymore like i
i've i went to um i went to a gay bar in
tampa
and um it could be just me being in my
own head i really don't know
my friends saw it too though so maybe it
wasn't just me in my own head there was
an older trans woman
assumingly a trans woman and i could
have sworn she was staring at me and my
first thought of course
is not that she's thinking about hitting
on me like my first thought is oh my god
this person knows who i am and thinks
i'm a transphobe and like is gonna
attack me and i don't wanna think that
way because
like that's assuming somebody's
something that they might not be
but it's gotten to that point people
like i said people used to come up to me
hug me now people at pride parades and
events will come up to me in private and
do one of these things
yeah do they do that to youtube like i
just want you to know yeah like i can't
say this out loud but i really really
appreciate what you're doing and i'm
like god damn it like
you can't say it louder like they they
won't do it they're terrified but most
you and i know at this point most people
agree with what you and i say
i i that's what i think too because i
don't think any
no nobody's happier because of this
thing you know it sort of was like
when when pride month rolled around or i
used to go to the the pride parade in
new york city which is always the last
sunday
of june and my birthday's my birthday is
june 26th so i actually
met my husband who i've now been with
for 10 years on my birthday
at gay pride i love that believe it or
not
and he was wearing an american flag tank
top it was it was all meant to be
i love it but but yeah when i would go
there then
people would sort of love me because i
had this radio show and i was a lefty
and i i don't really go to them anymore
but i did go to the abbey which is like
the big gay bar of west hollywood
uh i went about a year ago and for the
first time i was kind of worried because
i was like i don't know what these
people are going to think about me
exactly what you're saying
but i will say not only did nobody say
anything negative to me but several
people did come up to me and i could
tell they were a little nervous like oh
maybe i shouldn't be seen with dave but
they were like
dave i'm i'm with you so they are they
are waking up they are
cause gays are supposed to be
individuals not not group
monolithic thinkers yes that's the whole
point isn't it
like we're we're we were born different
i think and this is like a little
spiritual lesson but i think when you're
born different
it's a gift right it's a gift to
in in being yourself because you're
different is a gift because you allow
other people
the chance to be themselves you show
them that it's okay
and i don't i think if we are a monolith
i think that's the opposite of what our
path is as
lgbt people you know we have the
opportunity to be leaders and we're
being followers and
i refuse that you know are you hopeful
that we can turn this thing around it
seems like so
much of the woke thing is attached to
the trans thing where every day there's
another trans story i even talked
talk about it with my guys on the show
when we're figuring out the rundown and
i'm like i don't really feel like doing
another trans story
just because we're overblowing this
thing i've you know i'm saying with you
i don't care you i'll call you if you
treat me with respect i'll treat
you with respect i call caitlyn jenner a
she i don't have any problem with that
um but but that the issues these they've
just bludgeoned us with these issues to
the point
that i actually think they're starting
to cause a backlash i actually think
there's some backlash on the gays now
too
because of this because they feel like
oh see what happened the gays became
equal
and now look what happened now now boys
have vaginas and girls have penises
right no and i agree with them i agree
with the people that it is a slippery
slope i
i think which is why i call myself like
in this sense a conservative meaning
to me what a conservative means these
days is a classic liberal
and i think that's how you identify
correct me if i'm wrong yeah although i
don't have a problem saying conservative
at this point but yes my beliefs new age
conservatism
is classicalism and like just from
looking at
all the people who identify that way now
so that's where i've always been
um and the democrats progressives
liberals whatever you want to call them
on that side
it's just the most toxic behavior i've
seen from a group of people in a long
time
like i haven't even see i've never met a
religious person
that was far right that treated me that
way the way that people
do and they're telling you how tolerant
they are that's the beauty of it yeah
yeah that's well yeah that's that's
another abusive tactic right
gaslighting um like actual gaslighting
like i'm being nice i care about you
like nab like no
clearly you don't like you don't respect
me at all i think that
i think that we have a long way to go
because people are so
guilted right now into into virtue
signaling
and and trying to be the the most woken
the wokest or the most woke and
i think that's because there's an
extreme lack of self-awareness
and self self-worth from these people
that are that are doing this kind of
virtue signaling whatever you want to
call it they need to
be confident in themselves especially
the trans community
in my opinion i'm gonna get [ __ ] for
saying that but you know what it is what
it is
um anyone that that's that's very
different
needs to get their act together
be okay with being different and become
a leader and stop needing validation
they have to stop meeting and wanting
validation from everyone else
from the entire world and i think
once they do that and they show that
you know like caitlyn jenner i think is
a really good example to be honest
i think she is
she holds a lot of respect from a lot of
people
even if they don't agree with her being
trans not that you can't agree with
being trans because you can't fix it
help it but even if somebody disagrees
with her
i think they have a lot of respect for
her because she speaks logical
logically and i think that's that's
where the left is completely messing up
none of them are making any sense at the
moment none of them
it's all based on no it's all based on
identity politics
and you know people wanting to
be nice what do you uh what do you say
or what advice would you have if there's
like a young
gay kid watching this a 15 year old that
that
sort of understands that the woke thing
is wrong because we also know that now
the
the the zoomers the young generation
after generation y
they are leaning more conservative
because they've seen this thing go so
out of whack
but what would you say to a young gay
kid young girl who's who wants to come
out but doesn't want to be completely
uh just swarmed by that thing
it's tough because i've i get messages
more like that every day
than people assume i get hit on all the
time in my direct messages it's not like
that it's always these types of messages
like what do i do
i'm more conservative or i don't believe
in this crazy [ __ ] that they're spewing
i don't know how to speak up
you have to figure it out you have to
figure out how to speak up as long as
you're safe
um because in my opinion i think you
know this
if every single person that agreed with
us spoke up
this would end tomorrow it would end
tomorrow and today it really would
like it really would because there are a
lot more of us than them
and that doesn't that doesn't mean that
we're we're correct
on the issue just because there's more
of us but in this case i do think
you know it's just a bonus that there
happens to be more of us and we also
happen to be on the right side of
history so to speak pun intended i guess
my advice my advice would be you're born
to
do to be different and this is just
another chance to be
to be different and be proud of it to
think differently
everyone's scared these days to think
differently and if you can do that
and prove that that's okay and know that
that's okay to yourself and show others
that that's okay you're gonna be
the start of it's gonna be the start of
something big for them have you gotten
any real hate from people on the right
because i think for me what one of the
things that was kind of surprising was
that really didn't happen yes there's
this
very sl tiny sliver of anonymous weirdos
on twitter
who who seem to be on the right and hate
gays but in
reality whether i was sitting down with
ben shapiro who has a different
religious perspective
on gay marriage let's say or scary glenn
beck
or any of these people i found nothing
but support i found nothing but humanity
and decency
i go to evangelical events and get
standing ovations like
i just find tolerance there even though
perhaps they have a different
some of them have perhaps a different
religious belief
yeah i i people are going to think i'm
lying and drifting for this but like i
really haven't had any bad experiences
yet like
even when i like you said you disagree
with them they're like okay i don't i
don't agree but i still love you i still
respect you as a person okay like i'm
pro-choice i'm always going to be
pro-choice because i'm a traditional
feminist
um not these crazy third and fourth-wave
feminists oh my god
but yeah i think
yeah i don't i i think it's much better
on this side overall
like i i haven't really had any any like
even i met up with ben shapiro
and ben shapiro in l.a and he said the
most ben shapiro thing to me ever
and his little you know how he talks he
talks about do give me a bench
impression come on i'm gonna
i'm gonna try but he was like you know
you know the conservatives haven't cared
about gay since like 1990 right like
like so quickly like he shook his head
he did one of those things like you know
we don't care anymore right
and i was like i was like well now i
know like i didn't know before but he's
like yeah we nobody cares
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about women's
issues instead of non-stop yelling check
out our women's
issues playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell